okay today I'm going to talk to you
about melting and boiling points so I'm
going to show you how to figure out
which state different substances are
based on information about their melting
point and boiling point so first off
let's just imagine it is we're in a room
so our room temperature is let's say
this particular room is 20 degrees
Celsius so what I've got to do is given
this information I have to figure out
the state of these three different
things at room temperature 20 degrees
now you might already know or should
already know the state of the each three
of these would be in at room temperature
but I'm going to show you how we can
figure out let's say these were mystery
substances so first thing that you need
to do if you need to draw your self a
scale so it's like a temperature scale
like this so the most important things
we have on there well we have we mark on
zero degrees Celsius and we also mark on
our room temperature so a room
temperature let's say is right here and
let's say yeah for this room it's 20
degrees C okay now please please the
really important thing about this scale
this kind of temperature scale is it's
not to scale it's just rough
so we could get the idea of which
substance is going to be a solid a
liquid or gas at room temperature so
let's well in fact before we move on we
need to know what melting and boiling
actually means so just to be really
really sure that we do melting is when a
solid turns into a liquid so when the
particles are given enough energy I
overcome the forces to turn a solid into
a liquid now boiling so the boiling
point is when the particles have enough
energy so overcome the forces the liquid
in order to become a gas so boiling is
little turning from a liquid to a gas
okay so let's start off with oxygen so
here's my my temperature scale so here's
my room temperature here zero so the
melting point of oxygen is much less
than zero because it has this minus
number it's much less
and zero so it's all the way down here
so my melting point again remember it's
not to scale this is just getting the
idea relate in relation to zero and 20
and our room temperature where it is
so my melting point is minus 219 degrees
C okay so that's the amount of energy
required to turn solid oxygen into
liquid oxygen its boiling point is a
little bit less cold it's still a minus
number so it's not above zero so it's
gonna be somewhere like this so there's
the boiling point of oxygen which is
minus 183 degrees C okay so when I'm
figuring this out what I like to do
personally is I like to imagine we're
starting the left side of its melting
point so imagine we have solid oxygen
right here so what we need to do is
slowly we're gonna move until we get to
room temperature and think what's
happening to oxygen as we go this way so
the moment we have solid oxygen so as we
increase the temperature BAM we hit the
melting point right here at minus of 219
very low melting point so this means
this much energy had - 219 the particles
have enough energy to turn from a solid
to a liquid so now oxygen is in a liquid
state
remember we see when we get to room
temperature what state will be at room
temperature so let's keep on going so
you haven't reached there yet right BAM
a minus of minus hundred eighty three we
hit the boiling point that means there's
enough energy now to turn oxygen from a
liquid to a gas so oxygen is now in a
gaseous state so we keep on going it's
still a gas so when we get to a room
temperature of 20 we know that oxygen is
a gas
please remember this scale is not to
scale right so next up let's imagine
we're looking at water so again we look
at a scale when we mark on our melting
point and our boiling point so water's
melting point is zero so our melting
point is right there now the boiling
point is above room temperature because
room temperature remember in this case
is just 28 it's above room temperature
so a boiling point is 100 degrees
again this is nowhere near to scale I
just need to see where it is in relation
to room temperature is it above it or is
it below it so again let's imagine we'll
start this side of the melting point
this time with solid water called ice so
as we heat it up still solid still solid
BAM here we reach the melting point so
at this point here it's it's enough
energy to turn it from a solid to a
liquid so now water is a liquid so let's
keep going till we reach our room
temperature okay at room temperature
therefore water is liquid because we've
got enough energy for it to have turned
from a solid to a liquid but we haven't
got enough energy to turn it to a guess
we haven't gone over the boiling point
so as a result at room temperature of 20
degrees water is liquid so we can have a
look at the final one now I am so now I
on has a really high melting point again
this is not the scale we just need to
see where it is so it's above that 100
so let's say there's a melting point of
iron which is one thousand five hundred
and thirty-eight degrees C and there is
our boiling point of iron which is two
thousand eight hundred and sixty two
degrees C so again let's start right
down here imagine we have solid iron so
as we heat up the iron given the
particles more energy so but it's still
a solid because we haven't reached the
melting point right so at room
temperature it's a solid because we
haven't got enough energy to melt it we
have to get to one thousand five hundred
and thirty eight degrees C for it to be
a liquid so because that's its melting
point so that's how to do it so just a
quick recap the first thing you need to
do if you want to find out what state if
a substances are at room temperature is
you draw yourself a little scale it
doesn't have to be the scale you then
need to just draw in the melting point
of boiling point always imagine starting
a solid and working that way towards the
temperature you're trying to get to and
you can figure out which data is thank
you very much